[Musique]
j'ai regardé une ancienne photo de
classe avec mon grand qui est en grande
section de maternelle et je montrais bas
notre grande section de maternelle quand
j'y étais et j'ai remarqué que ça frères
30 ans dans un an et demi à peu près et
je me suis dit tiens ça serait sympa de
marquer le coup et pid de réunir tous
mes anciens camarades
bon ils ont tous trouvé ça très sympa
d'hommes projets s'ils sont devenus je
sais pas encore j'ai pas forcément voulu
les questionner parce que j'ai trouvé ça
sympa qu'on puisse garder tout ça pour
le jour j
donc on était 24 dans la classe et
aujourd'hui il me manque encore quatre
personnes
donc on voudrait
se retrouver à l'école et refaire la
photo à l'identique
j'ai vraiment d'institutrice j'en suis
ravi et
elle en est ravie aussi donc j'ai hâte
de pouvoir la revoir à nouveau il y a
la pauvre elle va se retrouver à nouveau
avec 30 élèves pas 30 24 élèves
elle a pu savoir où donner de la tête
[Musique]
ce